[Music]
the great transformation of the world
reassuring a world of sustainable well-being
it is a report that makes
radical proposals or we no longer have a
choice our globalized capitalist system
based on intense competition
in the short term and
exclusively the short  term on a
concentration of markets he says power
of economic decisions with
massive tax evasion organized on
a global scale has caused monstrous damage
has
[Music]
recently acquired for whom we hope
all economic enough knows the model
of the treaties even web  and this totally
plausible and braking and allen hamilton
the oval for me that the of an obvious in
trio and espresso or radical cambio or
trucks there in bio by albert de planeta
such person unfortunately gives no one to the
health of will be no more economic
development without its opposition between
8 the commission on two times and the
supporters admitted to line economic life
alone 8 of the seals chabanel enjoys the
crisis
I was there but there are solutions these
solutions must be fair because
we must be able to take the whole
population on board with us and above all, above all,
ensure that the middle classes and the working classes
are not
the major absentees because s  'they are
absent from the great transformation and
well there will be no transformation there
is no solution outside of Europe
and we must unite within the European Union
[Music]
[Applause]